[Music]
look at your hand how do you know it's
really yours it seems obvious unless
you've experienced the rubber hand
illusion in this experiment a dummy hand
is placed in front of you and your real
hand is hidden behind a screen both are
simultaneously strokes with the
paintbrush no matter how much you remind
yourself the dummy hand isn't yours you
eventually start to feel like it is and
inevitably flinch when it's threatened
with a knife that may just be a
temporary trick but it speaks to a
larger truth our bodies the physical
biological parts of us and our minds the
thinking conscious aspects have a
complicated tangled relationship which
one primarily defines you or yourself
are you a physical body that only
experiences thoughts and emotions as a
result of biochemical interactions in
the brain that would be a body with the
mind or is there some non-physical part
of you that's pulling the strings but
could live outside of your biological
body that would be a mind with the body
that takes us to an old question of
whether the body and mind are two
separate things in a famous thought
experiment 16th century philosopher Rene
Descartes pointed out that even if all
our physical sensations were just a
hallucinatory dream our mind and
thoughts would still be there that for
him was the ultimate proof of our
existence and it led him to conclude
that the conscious mind is something
separate from the material body that
forms the core of our identity
the notion of a non-physical
consciousness echoes the belief of many
religions in an immaterial soul for
which the body is only a temporary shell
if we accept this another problem
emerges
how can a non-physical mind have any
interaction with a physical body if the
mind has no shape weight or motion how
can it move your muscles or if we assume
it can why can your mind only move your
body and not others some thinkers have
found creative ways to get around this
dilemma for example the French priest
and philosopher Niccolo brownish claimed
that when we think about reaching for a
fork it's actually God who moves our
hand another priest philosopher named
George Berkeley concluded that the
material world is an illusion existing
only as mental perceptions this question
of mind versus body isn't just the
domain of philosophers with the
development of psychology and
neuroscience scientists have weighed in
as well many modern scientists reject
the idea that there's any distinction
between the mind and body
neuroscience suggests that our bodies
along with their physical senses are
deeply integrated with the activity in
our brains to form what we call
consciousness
from the day we're born our mental
development is formed through our bodies
interaction with the external world
every sight sound and touch create new
maps and representations in the brain
that eventually become responsible for
regulating our experience of self and we
have other senses besides the typical v
such as the sense of balance and a sense
of the relative location of our body
parts the rubber hand illusion and
similar virtual reality experiments show
that our senses can easily mislead us in
our judgment of self they also suggest
that our bodies and external sensations
are inseparable from our subjective
consciousness if this is true then
perhaps des cartes experiment was
mistaken from the start after all if we
close our eyes in a silent room the
feeling of having a body isn't something
we can just imagine away this question
of mind and body becomes particularly
interesting at a time when we're
considering future technologies such as
neural prosthetics and wearable robots
that could become extended parts of our
bodies or the slightly more radical idea
of mind uploading which dangles the
possibility of immortal life without a
body by transferring a human
consciousness into a computer if the
body is deeply mapped in the brain then
by extending our sense of self to new
wearable devices our brains may
eventually adapt to a restructured
version with new sensory representations
or perhaps uploading our consciousness
into a computer might not even be
possible unless we can also simulate a
body capable of delivering physical
sensations
the idea that our bodies are part of our
consciousness and vice versa also isn't
new it's found extensively in Buddhist
thought as well as the writings of
philosophers from Heidegger to Aristotle
but for now we're still left with the
open question of what exactly our self
is are we a mind equipped with a
physical body as Descartes suggested or
a complex organism that's gained
consciousness over millions of years of
evolution thanks to a bigger brain and
more neurons than our distant ancestors
or something else entirely
that no one's yet dreamt up if you'd
like to dig deeper into the mind-body
problem we highly recommend you read or
listen to I Robot by renowned science
fiction author Isaac Asimov you can
download a beautifully performed audio
version of this book for free by
visiting audible.com slash ted-ed every
free trial created through this link
encourages audible to continue
supporting our nonprofit mission so
thanks for watching and thanks for your
support